I'm a revolutionary biologist who came
to this late I'm trying to teach
evolutionary biology I suspect like
Richard might becoming an atheist and a
naturalist was reaction to the fact that
the opposition to what I was trying to
teach which was obdurate was based on
religious faith that you could not
dispel by teaching people effects of
that evolution I'm from that I became
transformed in theology I mean I
realized the way to get to keep
devolution was to get rid of religion
and then how do you do that well you can
reform society but you can also argue
against religion the new atheist have
done that very well I'm writing a book
now and that's one reason I'm interested
in this conference we've got the
incompatibility between science and
religion so there's a lot of areas in
there that I want to get people's takes
on at this meetings that involves
questions of three-way all questions of
mathematics questions about how we know
things are there other ways of knowing
things besides science I'm here I guess
specifically to address the question of
three well I guess I'm one of the few
incompatible lists in this group I guess
Alex is another one soon the other
question seems largely semantic and
since Sean brought this up in his
introduction I'll just respond to that
he had a theory that you know the free
will is compatible with determinism
because humans beat it rationally my
alternative theory is that were
collisions of molecules that prevailed
laws of physics and sometimes it appears
that we do that rationally but a lot of
times we doubt and our my replacement
for free will would be the statement our
decisions are made by internal forces
that we don't understand which is
deep-six the idea of free will in terms
of this statement on the terms of what
I've been willing to change my mind
about this is a question I've been
wrestling with for my book and I said
it's a powerful weapon in the
armamentarium of theologians there are
other ways of knowing besides science in
other words art literature music are
ways of knowing I want you to then
explain that question or so that's all
used justified religious ways of knowing
but
and I don't believe in that I don't
believe religion is a way of knowing but
I'm interested in understanding you know
and whether there are other ways of
knowing the science so about what that's
one definition ever or you know but in
that sense you could make a case that
there are ways of knowing beyond science
like when your kid tells you I'm hungry
okay those are justified true belief but
it's not attained through science I mean
you could test it through science but
you know anyway these are the kinds of
questions I'm completely open about this
I haven't decided I would like to think
that science answers all question in
that sense I would be a scientist
just a Rico summary who is and
everything of scientism none of that is
to justify religion but feel urgence use
art music and literature as ways of
knowing and from that in Jesus and
revelation is the way of knowing - so
I'd like to be able to discuss that
question I'm honored to be in this group
and which is a massive collation of
impressive neurons I like to ask what's
the benefit of myself and for the people
who are gonna be watching this YouTube
videos we try to stay away from specific
jargon it's particularly to our fields
because a lot of stuff that's going
around I don't understand very well
question of terms like homunculus
unction list right on my mind so I might
interrupt people have some to explain
bring up an idea Dan had that's
brilliant idea which is that what we
should have done is import for
undergraduates and then the demand that
everyone talking talk as if they are
talking to the undergraduate
you have to be proactive yes in your
hand oh saying what does that mean
I will actually yes so anymore
how's the asking question is here's the
risk of looking at you're in stupid I'd
rather learn then remain in the dark I'm
less there on the site which is related
open pessimist says I have a copy of my
popular book that I'd like to pass
around garena means for you to autograph
it's not for my backside I'd like to
sell it to the reuse of my website and
donate the proceeds to Doctors Without
Borders I think I could get at least
$2,000 worth so few of the that's so
kindness that just write your name I'm
Eeva statement about nationalist or
something that what during this week I
would be much gratified
you